we have an update on the dog poisoning
happening in a neighborhood of the lakes
a neighbor says requests for security
cameras were denied by metro police this
poison has killed three dogs and made
many others very ill kate houston live
near d-i and fort apache with what's
next
yes well sean cornwall has 30 security
cameras installed all around his home
after his dog leia died from poisoning a
few years ago he's been pushing for more
cameras to be placed around this
neighborhood after the person
responsible recently tried to poison the
dogs next door
sean cornwall says someone has been
throwing these balls of meat over his
neighbor's fences for seven years its
sorghum grain seeds soaked in strychnine
a highly toxic pesticide wrapped in
ground beef cornwall says the metro
department that authorizes the security
cameras said there were none available
despite these poisonings told to
cornwall and eight news now to be a top
priority cornwall says he hasn't seen
any action indicating this he wants
something to be done before another dog
or potentially a child ingests the
poison until it happens to you
in your in your backyard
you're
you don't really fully understand what
it feels like the violation
of
somebody
taking a life of one of your family
members that's that has no way to
protect themselves in a statement from
police it states in part the case is
under investigation they have to look at
the circumstances and the effectiveness
of putting up surveillance metro says
they also must consider other crimes
happening and only have certain amounts
of equipment they add hoas and
businesses have the option to install
their own surveillance
back out live cornwall is now taking
matters into his own hands partnering
with some animal rights groups to
develop some new methods to hopefully
catch the person who's responsible for
this now they are raising some money
through a gofundme and that's to keep
the reward separate that reward is ten
thousand dollars reporting live near
fort apache and desert and kate houston
live local now